board one Dimitri and ranking against
Magnus cars and I don't see the position
I don't know what some look at the game
and Drake wow six five versus nine
seconds but seconds seconds literally
a four a five Rook F4 and win for
Unbreaking it's very good to see five he
needs DB
three
King B3 okay King D4
the rookies Rook D4 this is very good
yeah
uh okay this is awkward three
okay check check King C3
goes for F5 F6 might still be winning
because when he wins The Rook gives The
Rook for an a pawn
right
yeah looks like looks winning
looks looks winning I mean he gives the
pawn for gives The Rook for an a pawn
right he takes the Rook for F Pawn and
then he's closer to the H board yeah it
seems so that should that should be
what
just like the king H5
King H5 is surprising
ly yeah it's still completely winning
still completely winning
yeah it's just over Queen yes what
that was I mean that was strange
takes
King F6 wow terrible six terrible
blunder
by Andre what happened H5 just f8 f8
cream first and then he would play King
G7 it was over incredible